congratulations on the movie
uh i had a blast watching it um i hope
it's a huge hit and that's all i have
i will see you later have a great day
i'm just joking
can you imagine okay bye thank you
if i'm not mistaken i believe this is
your first big hollywood movie
what do you wish you knew on day one
that you now
know everything was new everything was
different and
it was also my first movie speaking
english all the time
so everything was super challenging for
me
you know it was the first time i was
um i was traveling so far away from home
by myself and we first
shoot it in in vancouver and then we
moved to
japan so everything was like
am i dreaming or what is happening
um but i really enjoyed it
uh the thing that makes me feel
more proud right now
is that i'm able to understand english
100
you know because at the beginning it was
amazing i mean it was terrible
especially with andrew koji
he's british you know oh his accent
wow super british like he was i
i i heard like this all the time every
time he was saying something
i heard um that's all oh
so basically do you know charlie brown
the peanuts
right it was like charlie brown's
teacher you had no idea what what he was
saying
he was like huh
what what did you say
what are you talking about and he was
doing an effort and he was trying and
trying and trying
over and over again and but now i can i
can understand
him every single word he says what did
it mean to you
i think you're maybe you don't know this
but in america if you are a pg-13 movie
you can only say the word [ __ ] once and
what and what did it mean to you to have
your character be the one
being able to say it so proud
so proud because you know when i'm
speaking spanish
i use a lot of bad words right
so that defines me a lot i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a movie
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of snake eyes
everything i mean
i don't know for me everything was
mind-blowing
especially japan i was very excited
because it was my first time there
so everything the locations uh we were
shooting
some incredible places all over the
country
um we started in tokyo then we moved to
himeji
and osaka then we we went back to tokyo
so
for me the most mind-blowing thing
was japan yeah i can only imagine that
must have been amazing
before i run out of time with you though
when did it hit you
that money heist was so popular
that was crazy i mean i don't know if
you know that
um we
we shot them la casa de papel it was um
first and second season and it and it
was the end
it was like a closed show you know
so one year later uh netflix bought it
and this crazy thing happened with la
casa de papel
so all the cast we were doing we were
separate
a long time ago and we were doing
different things you know
so i realized when i was in argentina in
uh sorry in uruguay
with my boyfriend my boyfriend is from
there so
i remember we went to this very big
party
for a new year and
everybody was recognizing me and
i was in the y so i was like and
everybody was tokyo tokyo
you're a goddess you are the one you're
amazing and i remember i told my
boyfriend
how how which coincidence that
everybody that is recognizing me is here
in this in this in this body
you know what i mean because my brain
was like i mean
it's not possible and i remember it was
like
two days later than that um
the global premiere so
it was crazy and then i remember we were
talking
uh in this chat group with the cast from
la casa babel and everybody was like
hey guys my followers i mean uh
um i was one million yesterday and today
i have two millions i don't know what's
going on
this is crazy i mean is that happening
to you as well
and yeah it was
unexpected you know completely um i
already have to stop i'm just gonna say
congrats on being part of snake eyes
uh and i wish you nothing but the best
have a fantastic day
thank you you too